our next question is part f it sends us
back onto the complex plane it says the
points p and q represent the complex
numbers uh z1 which is equal to 4 plus i
and z2 which is equal to 1 plus 4i
respectively on an argon diagram the
point r represents
z1 plus z2 so show that the area of the
quadrilateral opqr
that oopsie daisy that area of that
quadrilateral is going to be 15 square
units okay so this is a proof question
right i've already been told what the
answer is ahead of time so how do i work
out what this is going to be equal to
but actually the reasons for it because
let's show that and that's why you can
see three marks are attached to this
all right to begin
when we have a go at this question
clearly the geometry of this is going to
be better to understand and easier to
reason through if i've got a clear sense
of that on my own diagram so um just to
make it a bit nicer for you guys i'm
just going to try and make this as close
to scale as possible let's draw
ourselves a nice neat
complex plane here
so um what we're gonna get here let's
write draw something like this
like so
and like this
okay here we go on the
real axis
and the imaginary
i know some people don't like it but
i've always been taught to put arrows on
both sides and there's our origin over
there on the right hand side and what i
say this was this is question f
okay now the particular points that have
been handed to us are
p which is at
4 plus i so i'm going to go over if we
say just looking at the scale here
i'm going to go and mark in
gonna go 1 2 3
4. so that's going to place point p
about there
this is 1 plus oopsie daisy it's going
to be 4 plus i
there's point p point q is
1 plus 4 i so therefore if i do the same
kind of 1 two three four but use those
points
or those lines rather that's going to be
lining me up about there so i'm going to
call that q which is equal to where we
just say 1 plus 4i all right so i've got
p i've got q r is the sum of those right
so what i can do is i can say being
especially that i'm headed towards a
quadrilateral right
i'm going to put this in let's keep
let's stay with black
i'm going to imagine this as the
oopsy daisy i'll do it from down here
the sort of concatenation of these two
vectors right oq and op if you do them
one after the other you get p plus q
right so therefore i'm going to take
this grab it over here
and that point that i've ended on up
there that should be r which you can see
is obviously going to be 5 plus
5i and just for good measure let's get
that whole parallelogram in there okay
so i want to show that this area
that'll lock in appropriately i think
that'll do we want to show that this
area is going to be 15 square units all
right
a bunch of different ways to do this
right
i'm going to show you actually three
methods for working out the area and
they each have their own attraction i'll
start with the most efficient one i'd
say because people like the quick answer
but then i'm also going to show you some
other methods that are you know they're
sophisticated they use a little more
advanced geometry not much advanced some
of them and they give you the answer
just or almost as efficiently as you
have to think of the advanced way okay
so when i have a look at this diagram i
notice that i don't just have a
parallelogram i also actually have a
rhombus right do you see that because
i've got a marketing like so because
i've got this side being equal to this
side and of course i have these two just
being you know translated versions of
those two vectors right
you've got a rhombus here and so one of
the ways to work out the area of a
rhombus is half times the product of the
diagonals half the product of the
diagonals because the diagonals are
perpendicular to each other if i draw
them in like so
i'm just going to i'll grab this and oh
i'll grab a copy of this and put it
somewhere else because i said i was
going to show you new solutions other
solutions later so let's just leave that
as a nice clean diagram
if i look at the diagonals like so so if
i draw this one here and this one here
because i have a pretty decent diagram
you can see that that's pretty close to
a right angle there right but the key
thing is it allows you to do
you know base times height oh sorry half
base times height half base times i half
base times height etc and when you
combine all of those you're just getting
you know all of those triangles all
together and that gives you half the
product of those diagonals okay
so therefore if i say okay well what are
those diagonals when you think about
this longer diagonal here it's going to
be
the distance of or the modulus rather of
z1 plus z2 so i can just work that with
pythagoras and then this one here
because i've got
p and q there's going to be a difference
here right so i can just do the modulus
of
if i call this right z1 take away z2
that's going to give me that distance
across there okay
in fact why don't we just work that out
while we're at it this distance across
here
you can see if i go from
[Music]
what's the best way to think about this
i'm going to think about it as
3
minus 3i because you can see i'm going
from q um to the right 3 units and then
down 3 units and that's going to take me
over to p right i mean i could have gone
in the opposite direction but because
i'm working out magnitude the sign
doesn't matter okay
so here if i work out first
o r
uh yeah i'll put the work in here o r
is going to be or its magnitude i should
say is going to be the square root of
5 squared plus pi squared this is just
pythagoras right 5 squared plus 5
squared which you can see i'm getting
from here
so that's going to be 25 25 underneath
the square root so this is
5 root 2 because i can take out the 25
or the square root of 25 factor i should
say 5 root 2.
and then when i'm working out that
magnitude of p q
that's going to be the square root of 3
squared
plus 3 squared
like so because you can see i'm getting
the 3s from here right i mean that
really should be 3 squared plus negative
3 all squared but you get the idea okay
so again same deal i can pull out that
square
um root of nine um
and then that leaves me with a two okay
so i can say now since
um
o p q r is a rhombus they already told
me it was a parallelogram and now i'm
reasoning that it's a rhombus because
o p
equals o q
the area
of o p q r i can appeal to the area
formula for a rhombus which is going to
be
half times the diagonals which we just
worked out were 5 root 2
and 3 root 2. so you're going to get
a half times 15 from the 5 times 3 and 2
from the root 2 times root 2 and that
gives you the 15 units squared
as required
so like i said i think that was a pretty
efficient way to go about it
and a handful of you did get this
solution but it wasn't the only way so
let's call this one
method one and uh let's have a go at a
secondary method uh yeah i'll just do it
all the way on this page that's fine no
need to move it method two
some fairly simple um you know right
angled triangle or not right angle
triangle some very simple trigonometry
is going to allow you to not just treat
this as a parallelogram but also as a
pair of triangles that you can work out
the area of of each of them very easily
because there's this congruence so you
only need to do it once in fact right
what i'm going to do here is think about
this parallelogram as just you know if
you think back to this diagonal here
if i take let's highlight it so let's go
like so that's too fat but i can adjust
it there we go
[Music]
close enough and let's get that style
right
that'll do me uh no you know what i'm
picky let's make that the right shade of
blue there we go that's better if you
have a look at that triangle there um
clearly um with the fact that this is
going to be a parallelogram you have
congruence right even if it wasn't
rhombus um you would still have
congruence between these two triangles
so if i can work out the area of this
triangle i just have to double it and
then i'm good to go right now there's
lots of ways to work out the area of
this triangle but a nice way to think
about it
is to take advantage of
what we know in terms of vectors right
because i can work out for instance
this angle in here let's call that theta
i can work out the angle between these
two vectors using the dot product you
might say oh that's really overpowered
but it's kind of a nice thing to use
because i have this side and this side
are trivially easy to calculate once
you've got that angle in there you just
go half a b sine c it's even nicer than
half a b sine c because you're going to
double it so you just get a b sine c for
this a this b and this particular c for
theta okay
so you've got the rough road map of it
let's have a go at like what does the
working look like right what i'm going
to do is i'm going to consider i'm
rather than calling this 4 plus i i'm
going to go into sort of vector mode so
i would call this 4i plus j
and for q
i would call this correspondingly i plus
4j right so when you're working out the
dot product you're just comparing the
i's and the js and multiplying through
appropriately so how am i going to write
this out well i would say
by the definition of the dot product
that
oq if i take the dot product of that
with o p what's that going to be equal
to it's the two magnitudes o q
ope
multiplied by cos of the angle in
between which i'm just calling theta but
it is i guess p o q right so i'm just
going to label that as actually no i'll
put that as p o q here because
everything in this line is in terms of
ps and o's and q's okay
so now let's go ahead and work out what
the dot product is it's pretty
straightforward you're going to get 4
times 1 and then 1 times 4. you can see
me comparing
this i
these i components and then these are j
components right so it's all nice and
straightforward
on the right hand side you can see i'm
just going to do pythagoras twice right
and it's going to be square root of 1
squared plus 4 squared which is 17 and
these two happen to be equal so that's
really nice
and then i just said let's call that
theta just for convenience right
so therefore what am i getting if i make
cos theta the subject on the left hand
side here i had 8 so that's going to be
8 there on the right hand side i had
this 17 here which i'm going to divide
through to make cos theta the subject so
you just get 8 on
and you might think
half of you are thinking those are
terrible looking numbers and the other
half of you are thinking those are
awesome numbers because you recognize
that these are actually part of an
integer
set of
pythagorean triplets right um the 8 15
17 triangles to be more precise so if
you have a think about a very quick and
dirty right angle triangle here
if you've got some theta
and i'm talking about cos right so
that's adjacent on hypotenuse that tells
you that the last side is going to be 15
that shorter side there right 8 15 17 go
ahead and check it out right
64 225 add them and you get 289 you're
like how did you know 17 squared was 289
well when you spend a lot of time
squaring numbers you'll get that right
so therefore that's what cos theta is
therefore sine theta is going to be just
15 on 17. and that should look very
suspicious that appears that 15 because
it's going to cancel with the 17 on the
bottom do you see where this is going
i'm going to say that area
o p r q it's double the area of this
blue triangle that i've just worked out
here which is opq so let's call that
triangle opq which is 2 times here comes
just the area formula right it's half
a
b
sine c which in this case is sine theta
i already know what that is so i'm
getting
the two times a half they're just going
to cancel i'm going to get 17 times 15
on 17 which is the 15 square units that
i was looking for in the first place
okay so that was a second method now uh
i was a bit silly i did this neatly
before but i forgot so let's just grab
this again it's a bit messy i have to
delete some stuff let's have a look at
one more um it's it's slightly hilarious
in terms of being overpowered but it's
it's a great use of the technique which
i really enjoyed seeing when um i saw a
student do it so let's just get rid of
all that
just call that
p
and q
and i don't need this anymore um we use
the dot product just now right so that's
a pretty sophisticated technique when
you think about the fact that i'm just
in like you know td vectors right but um
if you want to think about an even
funnier more sophisticated but once you
see a very clever way of doing this
i'm not going to use the dot product to
work out that angle i'm going to do get
ready for it
a projection right i'm going to do a
scalar projection in fact just to work
out a particular length here that's
going to help me evaluate this area
let's go back to the fact that this is a
parallelogram right
in my first method i took advantage of
the fact that this particular
parallelogram is a rhombus as well so i
used the area formula for a rhombus but
if you didn't know that or if you didn't
think your mind didn't go there you
might think well what's the area of a
parallelogram if i don't like you know
slice it up into chunks like triangles
right
and it just so happens you may recall
this right that if you think about a
parallelogram
any arbitrary parallelogram is really
just like a rectangle that's had a bit
sliced off there and and moved over
right so if you think about
this bit over here it's congruent to
this chunk over here so if you just
moved it over you would get a rectangle
from that parallelogram that number one
it has the same perpendicular height
like so and number two it has the same
uh sort of base length i guess you would
call it right so we know that the area
of a rectangle is base times time so
therefore the area of that parallelogram
is the perpendicular height times the
base so if you can work out what that is
you're good to go right now in order to
do that for this particular
parallelogram the perpendicular height i
can work out with the help of a
projection right so let me see if i can
get this right
if i think about the fact that say uh
you know looking at let's let's
highlight it like so looking at this
vector here i'm going to call this
oq right and if i think about the
projection of oq onto ope so what i'm
imagining is i'm sort of dropping down
this perpendicular and this is the
perpendicular height that i want so i'm
just going to call this h if that's
perpendicular there right the projection
onto it is going to be here right now
the projection is not the theme that i
want the projection though with the aid
of pythagoras will help me work out this
perpendicular height and once i've got
that i already know that this is going
to be the square root of 17 or if i was
doing this method from scratch like it's
not hard to work out that is square root
of 17 so then here is my base multiply
by my height and i'm good to go okay so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to use
this right here i'll keep this in purple
this thing is the projection of
oq the blue onto op that black one down
the bottom so i'm going to write that as
projection of
it's on to op and it's of o q
okay are you following
so there's lots of different ways to
work out what a projection is but in
this context i think doing
op.oq
and then dividing by the magnitude of op
is probably going to be one of the more
convenient formulas that i use for this
projection okay now i'm going to cheat
just a little bit because we've already
worked out some of this before but you
can work this out from scratch if you
wanted
i already know this dot product it's um
do you remember this is 4 times 1 plus 1
times 4 so you're just going to get 8 on
that numerator there
and by the same token i've already
worked out this length op a number of
times it's the square root of 17 so i'm
just going to pop that on the bottom
there so once you've got that okay how
do i use that in this right angled
triangle what i can say is and let's
just grab this just to make it a little
easier to see what triangle i am talking
about
that
is a bit sneaky and cheap but i'm gonna
ride with it okay what i can say here is
that
in that triangle i can say that this
shorter side
plus
this other shorter side so i'm taking
the scalar
um
actually i don't really need to say that
because this this
should have this around it like so
the scalar projection like so is going
to be that other shorter length and what
that's going to be equal to is
the hypotenuse all
squared like so okay
so you can see in fact i should have
that in blue because that's what that um
that's what i marked it in
like so okay
so
that h squared i'm going to leave that
as the subject and on the right hand
side i already know what oq is it's
square of 17 so when you square it you
get
17
and then i'm going to subtract this
particular projection in here i should
have said by the way that's squared
that's very sneaky because this is
pythagoras after all so therefore this
result here is being squared so it's 64
on 17 i hope you can see that numerator
and denominator being separately squared
so therefore what am i getting i've got
h squared equals now this is 289 on
17 because i'm just squaring that right
so when you subtract 64 does this sound
familiar it's pythagoras all over again
this is going to give me 225 on
17 so therefore the height is going to
be 15 on the square root of 17 since of
course
it's positive
so therefore finally
since opqr
is a parallelogram as given in the
question
the area is just base times height
so area
equals all right the base is um just
going to be i'll write base times height
just to make it clear what i'm
multiplying
so this is going to be
that magnitude of op which we already
know multiplied by
h that's the base and that's the height
that i'm looking at in this particular
case
are you sick of me yet writing the
square root of 17
multiplied by 15 on the square root of
17 so that's why you get one last time
the 15 square units as required and one
of the things i love about this is that
to get that 15 everything always cancels
right
these awkward irrational numbers cancel
here when you have a look at our
previous method um they weren't
irrational but they were just weird
looking that they appeared there in the
denominator um and then here it's the
it's the those are rationals and that
half they cancel so it's just a perfect
example of the the beautiful son of
symmetry that you get from considering
geometric situations from multiple
angles